the nhl playoffs are underway and
unfortunately for the first time ever
without the golden knights among the
ranks today the team held a press
conference to wrap up their season
players are already looking ahead to the
next season 8 sports now reporter kevin
martin is live with more good afternoon
kevin
coming into the season the golden
knights had stanley cup aspirations but
after a slew of injuries the golden
knights failed to make the playoffs for
their first time since entering the
league in 2017 and those injuries were a
huge story for the golden knights this
season they lost close to 500 man games
this season including many of their top
players max pacioretti captain mark
stone alec martinez and even robin
leonard and that definitely took a toll
especially as it related to max
patcheretti and stone who missed half of
the season but the players aren't using
that as an excuse
i don't think i put my finger on one
thing
i mean i wasn't really in the locker
room for that long either which is
not ideal
only played 37 games so
but you know we had
40 people walking in out of our locker
room this year was a
interesting year on that side of things
and
you know i think we just couldn't get
couldn't get it back on the rails in the
end to get in
so not only will the golden knights use
this extended off season to get healthy
they enter the off season 13 million
dollars over the salary cap so we will
definitely see some changes within the
roster reporting at city national arena
kevin martin live local now